[Music]
did you guys see
this crazy video did you
just kidding no it wasn't it was a
little girl that got like
whipped up yeah yeah oh is it the kite
thing
oh and then what happened i want to see
okay did you see you didn't see this
video
oh my god i was so scared different
perspectives okay
this is the first one
what are they doing it's a kite you just
gotta watch you still watching oh no
it's awful
look at that cool kite oh there goes
that oh no
oh no attached to the back side
that baby got a strong grip oh please
god what happened
okay if i was that kid i'd be like
save i saw this and i was like but
letting go
you don't have a parachute did that did
that kid let go
oh [ __ ] you'll hear it oh
imagine when it whips i think that's the
one i saw i wait why was the kid
connected to it i'll tell you in a
second
oh it wasn't just holding on yeah no it
looked like it was connected to the
chest
so that's so in the first video how you
guys saw that the
the guys they were prepping the kite and
stuff so they can go it was very windy
day
somehow during that moment the
the kite like wrapped around this
three-year-old
around three-year-old three-year-old
around their entire body
and they just swung like just imagine
the parent and like like
oh [ __ ] that's funny
how the [ __ ] did it wrap around a
three-year-old
it was whipping around really fast so
yeah she was just
yeah exactly and it was about did she
come down laughing
she went up a hundred feet but they
should come down laughing
she i don't know if she was laughing but
she did when she came down
cause kids love that [ __ ] they examined
her
not taika he'd hate it to see if like
she had anything broken or anything
crazy
they're saying that she was okay she
just had like some like scratches
oh i take it with a daredevil he has his
gene where he's kind of
like afraid of heights like he's kind of
weary of it like he'll be like oh so
scary so
when i threw him up he used to like
laugh like crazy is he different now
yeah yeah if i throw him high he gets
kind of scared way more aware
i remember he used to go and i'm all
woo hoo no okay
super fast they need to know who they
are i hate this multiple personality
[ __ ] they got
wait you have multiple personalities i'm
an adult they need to know who they are
okay i'll let them know i have a pep
talk yeah let them know
say hey hey bud yeah what's up with this
like
i can't follow who you are yeah one day
you're happy the next five minutes
you're sad and then you're screaming
what the [ __ ] do you want who are you
yeah come on man we need to have a talk
yeah okay stabilize your ass
i know it's really strange because like
one year they're super into legos and
all this [ __ ] and the next thing you
know is just video games all day every
day and they just throw it all away
you know how much money i just spent on
those 10 legos wait are you talking
about your kid or
joe it applies to both okay
all right who knows i do want some legos
just the other day i'll give you isaac's
old legos
i want my old legos you get your own my
old legos
i want my old legos the only legos that
matters is the 90s legos
you know they're identical less shapes
they change
they change same shape it's been pet
patented
i gave uh isaac
the delorean because he like back to the
future
that [ __ ] was like 200 bucks yeah i bet
really
it was special i was like it's like i
threw that [ __ ] away
i didn't throw it away he absolutely
[ __ ] loves it till this day that's
one of the ones that
that he kept like he kept some legos
that he just will not get rid of i think
the dorian's one of them was that before
or after got the bio fuel thing in the
back
i don't know the difference yeah you
really know you're like you know when no
no
you know how like when he went back in
time it was like the normal
delorean but when he went to the future
it had like some biofuel thing in the
back and he could put trash
with it yeah yeah with that they made
little who knows
but they shot it at the puente hills
mall oh yeah
they did so anyways so the little girl
is okay
they were just saying like it just
happened in an instant we don't even
know
how this even came to be but you can see
like
in this photo is uh you can see how this
the the kite actually got wrapped around
the torso
so i can't see [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna make
it i'm so glad that that happened
and it wasn't just relying on the girl's
strength i thought she just had crazy
strong strength
strength oh my gosh she would have been
she would have died
yes that looks dangerous though it
doesn't look like she's holding it
it looks fun that's it you would want to
do something whip me around like that
like where i'm just chilling and it goes
whoa man i'm just in the air flying not
holding on to [ __ ] i'm down
i think the most similar thing might be
bungie yeah cause you're going down
but i like that feeling of like oh
you're like in a [ __ ] chinese kite
dance you know like
you know how they got the [ __ ] swirls
and [ __ ] yeah but you you are the yeah
are like the olympic uh the olympians
that go like this
oh dude i wanted those so bad like the
the ribbon with the on a stick thingy
that looks so funny you get like you're
throwing around and you feel like that
[ __ ] car lot dude the [ __ ]
waiver wacky wacky guy yeah that's scary
man
yeah i think the scariest thing about
this is that like she's not just like
flying in the air or even super high up
it's the whipping part yeah
right 30 seconds yeah that alone should
give her some whiplash oh my god snap
her neck
how did she finally come down was it the
weight it was the yeah it was the wind
that it just allowed her to dip it in a
little bit too right
um maybe maybe they shouldn't fly kites
with children around or they should just
set a parameter like how we do it out
here that's irresponsible for them
yeah so that's who would have thought
you're right asian don't care about this
[ __ ]
safety now they'll care probably right
because immediately after this incident
the festival shut down uh they called
out the event
and and then they said that
so the government the city government's
team
offered a sincere apology to the victim
and the public
and then said that they're going to be
launching an investigation
why they use the word launch
they're such a pessimist though they
should have been like we're celebrating
the life of this child
they lived you know turn it around oh
yeah they did say that they're gonna
look into this incident to prevent
this accident from happening again in
the future yeah i wonder if the kid's
gonna remember any of this [ __ ]
at three i i think i'll remember i would
i think i would also your family would
keep telling you about it
and then you see the video yeah and you
have the video yeah
because i actually remember like when i
because i there's only one
um childhood video of mine and i
remember
that time because of the video like it
helps me remember be there even more so
for sure this little girl's gonna
remember
i have no video but i do have snapchat
snapshots of certain memories
that i shouldn't have because i was like
too young like i was like one or two or
whatever and one of them was eating soap
it was so [ __ ] gross you had a photo
of you eating no in my
in my
yeah my mom was like yeah i remember
that because i was telling her i was
like hey
did i ever get into some soap because i
remember it was
so [ __ ] disgusting but i thought it
would be delicious
and then like i was chewing on a bar of
soap and
she's like yeah it took forever to wash
her mouth out with
like i imagine she's like rinse your
mouth out with water but just keeps
coming out bubbles and she's like
keep going keep going like a toddler
or younger like i wasn't i couldn't
communicate so she had to stick her
finger in and [ __ ] rinse it out yeah
isn't that a punishment for kids like if
you say a bad word
to put the soap in your mouth from the
christmas story remember here like he
held the bar of soap in his mouth
i don't know my mom that's some crazy
torture back then huh you took that
punishment away from your mom
she's like [ __ ] he likes it i gotta take
something out
he tried to eat so that was actually the
case uh because my mom would
she would make us eat chile if we were
misbehaving or something she was like
i'm gonna give you chile
so then we end up eating it it's all
spicy in our mouth and [ __ ] but then uh
one of my brothers he actually liked it
so
now you eat the spiciest one popcorn
chicken spiciest she couldn't discipline
him
for that should have kept it a secret
she had to get
creative yeah that must be a core memory
for you
you know everyone has like at least like
five to ten core memories
that you build within your childhood
even if it's stuff that you don't
understand
so maybe that you're just remembering
how it tasted
and not the visuals but then you're
piecing it all together i remember
yeah i mean i remember the hallway with
in that house
it was our first house i remember yeah
there was and then i have photos
of the of me in the yard uh um
in this like pool and so i rem
like i have pictures of the outdoor
garden but not the indoor but i know i
remember what it looks like and i
explained to my mom she goes yeah that's
what it looks like yeah
it's crazy yeah and then they say like
memory you don't remember [ __ ] until
like after you're a toddler or whatever
most people there's this one screenshot
of this little girl
i don't know why am i mean it kind of
looks funny it looks like she's walking
honestly nice that whole thing looks
funny
it looks funny it is anyone being thrown
around like that looks funny
but she wasn't even like her her limbs
weren't
like flailing around holding on to dear
life
maybe it was fine for her i'm sure that
just the parents were really traumatized
every other parent there i wish that
their kid would imagine how awkward it
would have been if they didn't shut it
down like how do you [ __ ] fly a kite
now
and like you're like just forget guys
forget it that would have been hella
awkward nothing happened good thing that
didn't happen delete everyone's videos
and stuff
yeah i know luckily she's okay though
because that could have been really bad
i did some crazy uh [ __ ] one time
when i was a kid again i think it was
like
five-ish or something right my mom
always tells the story but we were
picking up
my grandma from the airport and i was
super happy to see her
so you guys know an lax it's like a loop
right so
we parked in the middle parking lot and
then
you had to go to like the the tom
bradley which is the international
airport which is like across the street
in between there's two like on there's
there's traffic going one way
and then on beyond that there's like a
car that's like
area for pickup right as soon as i saw
my grandma
i [ __ ] ran like a [ __ ]
straight to her
and then all of these cars started
stopping and then this bus
just stopped and [ __ ] in front of me
yeah
and then my mom was like oh no and i had
tunnel vision so i just [ __ ] booked
it and i was like i could
outrun these cars i need to see my
grandma yeah
damn and then i and then i i don't know
i was in deep [ __ ] and i was like but
i was like it's okay because god saved
me
and then i you little [ __ ] he actually
did because
yeah i'd kick your ass for just saying
that be like [ __ ] you
you little [ __ ] gave me a heart attack
it's not a joke
man you and bart were handfuls as babies
you